première année pour moi d'autres ça
remonte jusqu'à ce niveau au loft année
c'est vraiment jamais vu qu'est ce qui
fait que cette année les inondations
sont si importantes
alexandre la flamme nous écrit beaucoup
de personnes attribuent les inondations
au changement climatique mais est ce
vraiment le gars est d'abord est-ce
inédits deux grandes inondations comme
ça en trois ans c'est très exceptionnel
je suis 100 blanche journaliste
spécialisé en environnement radio canada
alors le changement climatique est il en
cause
pas si sûr que ça en fait les experts
par exemple chez ouranos disent le
contraire
les projections des modèles climatiques
parle d'une réduction de la durée de
l'engagement de 45 à 60 jours sur le sud
du québec d'ici 2070 et donc la forme de
cette neige au printemps va créer de
moins en moins de pression sur les cours
d'eau et donc en principe avec le tas il
devrait y avoir d'un site québec -
d'inondations père tanière il y en avait
par le passé
le réchauffement climatique apportera
plus de pluie il est principalement en
été et en automne la question portait
justement aussi sur les précipitations y
at il eu plus de chutes de neige et de
pluie que dans les années précédentes
qui est le mieux placé pour répondre
pascal yiacouvakis métérologue bénin
pour radio canada
oui il a beaucoup plu une passablement
depuis beaucoup plus que la normale à
montréal par exemple 50% de plus que la
moyenne
entre novembre et avril et quand on
regarde le niveau du fleuve c'est leur
abaya réagi en conséquence parce que
tout au long de l'hiver s'est maintenu
au dessus de la normale et la façon dont
on construit aggravent les conséquences
des inondations
l'urbanisation des territoires a une
influence sur le
la gestion de l'eau par exemple l'île de
laval l'époque ce tournoi de montréal
était un grand marécage y avait en effet
éponge laval ne redeviendra pas un
marécage
mais il faudra réfléchir à la protection
des zones sensibles